from The Kids Are Alright which airs
tonight in every single Tuesday on ABC
at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time Michael
Cudlitz good to see you sir how are you
so you are from we just chit-chatted
back back down from Staten Island you
are from flushing flushing right in the
right in the home of the New York Mets
pretty much right I have memories I
think they're memories unless your
actual memories your memories from
seeing the photograph so many times yes
right memories of walking under
underneath a big aviary it's still there
from the 64 World's the world World's
Fair yeah where men in black took place
exactly exactly
yes I still want to drive by from the
airport coming in from JFK the city you
go oh I remember I remember right so
that's we did you really grow up that
right Christ on the other side of the
Parkway so you were there you well till
I was five okay then I when you knew
okay then you move to Jersey yet so just
kind of like the Jets also the New York
Jets played and started in Jersey which
is in New Jersey that's right
I know Buffalo Bills fans will always
say that they're the only team in New
York State cuz the Giants yeah it's
exactly Jersey yeah everybody's planning
another state so like the Anaheim deal
with those Angeles Angels they are that
yeah they sure they are they are they
are
we're on angels radio AM 8:30 right now
say hello to the Los Angeles Angels fan
I'm sure you're all really pleased about
this I don't really have a stake in this
but I'm sure there's a lot of angels
fans that are really happy that they are
the Los Angeles Angels right so when you
grew so you grew up a fan of which team
in New York City not none of them really
I I enjoy watching sure you know I'm
sure this will play really well with the
audience we're talking but never a
specific team fan a fan of sports love
right I mean these are you know
world-class level athletes so then which
athlete did you emulate growing up I
guess the last sort of thing group
person I followed would be Fran
Tarkenton okay Minnesota Viking sure we
all said Tommy Giants - yeah yeah but
it's you know that was the land for me
free agency ruined a lot of it you know
it's it's kind
reminds me of like when I when my car
got broken into the first time I had all
my my my cassettes stolen my cassette
collection you know you're kind of like
well I'm never gonna collect music
anymore because if it can all get taken
away that easily I feel the same way
about the sports team so it's like Who
am I following I'm following a team
that's gonna you know pick up and move
in the middle of the night it's because
they can do that now right following a
team that's gonna fall apart because you
know you got a guy running into the
endzone yeah number one team's getting
its butt kicked sorry there's nothing
it's like he's worried about his stats
that's like the Seinfeld joke that you
root for laundry that it doesn't matter
who's in it you just root for the actual
you yeah you know so unless you're in
Green Bay then you're like you know cuz
it's not going anywhere because they own
it right that's the mean so it's still
one of the teams where you sort of like
I can I can get behind my buddies a
Green Bay Packers fan and owner and it
and it's amazing so in this analogy
Michael Cudlitz
here on the Richard Rowe in this analogy
when Indianapolis took the Colts out of
Baltimore in the middle of the night
they were the thief that took your
cassette collection my mother's car yeah
okay yeah what was the collection of I
mean would you have lost it to that time
I've been all 70s rock well Mike I mean
that's your that's your that's your
that's your bailiwick over there 70 did
you ever have a cassette collection just
still nice at a track
did you steal Michael's collection you
lived in New Jersey was the car broken
into in New Jersey it was he was a cop
in New Jersey and a terrible cop at that
yeah
the Bad Lieutenant and also disc jockey
breaking into Michael's car to take his
to take his case was you it was you all
along I'm sorry I do have a confession I
still have a cassette collection do you
really yeah it's probably 500 600 of
them what do you do with eight boxes I'm
transferring them into recording them so
you can actually do this at that time if
we find them we can transfer them for
you what do you think yeah Michael I
don't know like for 20 bucks
hey Alexa man Michael Cudlitz here on
the Rich Eisen show is it true you broke
into acting your initially working on
sets is that a well I didn't I didn't
break into it that way I used
construction to for film and television
to pay my way through school and it was
okay acting school so how'd you get the
acting bug I've been doing it since the
third grade you know my folks tell me
about when I used to sit in front of the
television and sort of get up and act
out the commercials mm-hmm which I just
I believe them I don't remember it yes
sir to leave them but and it makes sense
because they're you know the commercials
used to have and products used to have
jingles so there was like something you
could get behind you
Oscar Mayer wiener and of course Big Mac
two all-beef patties special sauce
lettuce cheese pickles onions on a
sesame-seed bun there's things you can
you know you're literally like I know it
you're like yeah you're a complete
victim of marketing good for you I know
I know it what's the beef
you know Wendy's see still sticks with
me so which set were you working
carpentry on to I did early on I did a
lot of b-movies but early on the sort of
like them my first long-term job in
construction was on the set of Beverly
Hills 90210 the original so which
there's a kind of interesting story of
that because I've built the converted
all the stages mm-hmm that we were on
that we were working on for Beverly
Hills 90210 in Van Nuys and now we're
shooting The Kids Are Alright on come on
those stages get out of here yeah so
you're like walking around saying I used
to I used to no I'm not because it's
like weird too young to be full circle
with anything it's like it's all come
full circle like like what's next death
completed later no but these are humble
beginnings and but it's and so you went
from building the sets to acting on the
set on that show yeah I actually I
remember being pulled into the audience
an audience in the office right with
plot way ignorant some the execs on from
Aaron Spelling yeah
and they'd said hey we know you're you
know you're doing all the construction
on the show and smacking this mic every
chance don't worry it's okay and but we
know you're an actor but we just can't
have you on the show like you can't you
know if there's any you're thinking
about acting on the show you really
can't because conflict of interest and I
said conflict of interest what like yeah
but I was fine somebody's part you just
loosen the I don't know where this was
coming from from their end but I was
that's fine so one of the first movies I
ever did a river runs through it came
out shortly after that meeting and then
we had a another meeting where they knew
that they were having trouble casting
some some roles right because they
needed bigger guys that looked young and
they came to me
River Asura came out they pulled me in
the office and they said okay we we
didn't know you were really an actor so
we had this thing we want you to do I
said what happened to the whole conflict
of interest was it like a conflict of
your interest or my interest was
perfectly fine I said okay I'll yeah
let's do this
what was your role I played Tony Miller
I took Brenda to the prom I was
introduced in the steroid episode where
we were gonna beat up Steve you are
juicing on Beverly you know that's what
I kind of loved about the show it
actually for its time was really dealt
with a lot of a lot of stuff the kids
were dealing with you know you look back
at it and you yes was it a soap opera
it's hard but was it dealing with all
these social issues we were dealing with
you know anorexia and bulimia eating
disorders SUEZ teen suicide we were
dealing with rape they would they were
dealing with a lot of really heavy
issues Chuck Rosen was responsible for
all that and just I think did a
phenomenal job connecting with the
people of that age during that time you
know a lot of people grew up on that
show and it was something that was was
going on at the time sure and it was an
interesting take on you know exploring
that
the way we could you know is all a lot
of it was fairly superficial but that's
to me that's a really wonderful way to
introduce something and let people know
that they're not alone
in whatever struggles are going sure did
you ever meet the Big Cheese Aaron
Spelling did you ever meet him I met
Aaron a couple times yeah okay he was he
was very very accessible you know that
was part of from what I understand is
the history of there's a lot of security
around him because early on because he
was so accessible
his family was this is how we remember
it so if I'm getting this wrong and
anyone's gonna be this is you're happy
about it is social media it's how I
remember it okay
you've said people and you know they
were there were threats against his
family of kidnapping and such so he was
very very insular with his with his
security but with his with his crews and
the people that worked with him was very
giving and loving and present that's
great Michael Cudlitz here on the Rich
Eisen show when you look back on your
time on The Walking Dead what do you
think of sir just wonderful storytelling
really great friends and possibly the
worst working conditions so far as
weather I've ever experienced but I mean
they just the rain and the heat and the
humidity and you know which was all part
of the show and which is what I think
helps make the show as good as it is
right the the environment is actually
another character that you have to deal
with you wake up today and you're like
okay it's hot it's miserable and you
guys are cranky okay got it it's like
okay we're there and what are your views
on like me I mean I could talk about
what happened your character but really
is it a spoiler alert I mean like no
seriously yeah I mean what is what is
the philosophy but for somebody years
even years later what is your philosophy
as an actor because we talked about this
with Game of Thrones right now like how
too soon is too soon because obviously
what happens with your character is such
a major yeah like a week grace period a
week yeah and then everything on you
look if you're the one who's gonna pack
their stack everything up and
right it's on you to not you know it's
like I'm sorry the whole world has to
not talk about something that they're
experiencing together because you are
not fitting it into your schedule right
it's on you okay because again yeah I
mean you're part of that show a
significant yeah
massive following that had a ton of
spoilers yeah and you're you were part
of one in a way and we actually Stephen
and I had to keep our secrets for more
than a year for yeah but big secrets
like that are easy to keep because you
know you just can't talk about it okay
the smaller secrets that happen during
the season which are harder because you
lose track of where you are in the app
to show you sort of like horses did that
area did that not air see right and one
thing affects something down the road so
you kind of realize you kind of maybe
tilt your hand a little bit on a smaller
thing that wasn't supposed to be known
because it affects so many other things
down the road but when it's a big thing
you just don't talk about it and how
many people come up to you and ask you
about Southland still owe a lot it
amazing yeah we do these conventions for
Walking Dead and a lot of the parents
come you know and a lot of law
enforcement it's it was a amazing time
in my life and an amazing sort of way to
get to spend time and and learn more
about my city mmm there are areas that
we went into that I never you know if
you watch the news there's a whole chunk
of the city you should never go near if
you actually spend time in that city and
the wonderful neighborhoods and the
people there it's it's phenomenal you
ever want to do it again oh yeah yeah I
think we'd all go back everybody yeah
cuz you guys have all gone into some
bigger and better as we all know were
just different georgina bigger and
better
I shouldn't say better you're right yeah
but no no but he's all gone on two
completely different others and had
success at it yeah but you think you and
Ben McKenzie and Regina King would all
get it right you do all come back
together yeah yeah that was some of the
the most creative storytelling I think
that any of us have ever done so what's
what's holding you back I just think
somebody doing it you know I know I
believe that John Wells would actually
approach Netflix at one time
I'm I just I don't know if at the time
there was the interest mmm
but I I foresee the potential of it
still I mean so much is being brought
back in a way from comedy willing grace
I can't wait for the Deadwood movie
coming out next tell me about that last
night you know it's kind of like whoa
right exactly so why not one I don't I
don't I don't know why why not and I'm
in agreement with you I think personally
I'd love to do something like they did
with with the Sherlock series you know
do two or three yes every sort or so and
kind of dip in to see where these people
are and how they've evolved and I think
we could do some really enough they've
been doing that with Luther also on BBC
as well okay yes I think we don't do it
out you know what I will I would I would
pay to see that yeah I done Wells get on
it okay yes watching or somebody charge
whatever wherever you are and whatever
you know got your water skiing behind
leader off at Warner Brothers let's do
that and let's talk about The Kids Are
Alright right now a nice throwback from
the 70s family of eight there we go boys
eight boys which definitely was not
eight is enough
hey um I've had to deal with nine
children there you go boys and then you
and Mary McCormack plays your wife yeah
she's awesome she's amazing she's all
kinds of great yeah what do you like
doing about this show Michael uh so much
the kids are amazing actually the actors
that we have but for me it was is a big
shift in my career I needed a need a
moment you know we talked about the band
of brothers in Southland and walking
dead and I had been carrying a gun
basically for 15 16 17 years I you know
I wanted and I've said this before so
it's not it's not a new shtick but I
wanted to be able to walk into a room
and feel like I didn't have to clear it
before I could have a conversation with
somebody um they got tired of killing
people on screen I'll go back to that
but there's nothing like it's like
that's this drama I'm you know conflict
and drama and I get it but I would never
you know I'm just tired of doing it and
then next month I'm doing it again in
people like your ally
I'm like no I mean I'll go back to it
but I just needed to laugh at work for
all the right reasons okay well it's on
every single Tuesday including tonight
on ABC at 8:30 p.m. Eastern time and
it's been granted like I've told you a
backstage we've had so many of your
colleagues on the show it's it's great
to have you here from Regina King to Ben
McKenzie and it's funny Jeffrey Dean
Morgan when he sat on that couch it was
very comfortable holding that back yeah
I bet he was way back with bags huge
history with that with bets do people
come up and say I miss Abraham or you
know oh my gosh you know Abraham was
possibly my favorite character can you
sign my back yeah there's team Meegan
t-shirts on we miss you so much
like so much that you couldn't have
gotten my t-shirt that's the way fans
are that's where fans are no they love
the show they do love the characters I
love the character of negan so I get it
you know it's it's I think the
characters especially the the graphic
novel characters are so well developed
you can't help the phone though with
them right well it's great to have you
here I hope you come back soon sir
yeah well good to have here at cutlets
certainly to promote the new reboot of
Southland yeah absolutely that we have
just created here in our best of our way
out cutlets on both Twitter and
Instagram Michael Cudlitz here the kids
are all right tonight on ABC in every
Tuesday at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app